typography is an essential part to any
motion graphic project in this video I'm
going to show you five typefaces that
every motion designer should be using
[Music]
hey everyone Cameron with motion science
and in this video I'm going to show you
the five typefaces I think you should be
using your projects now I know what
you're thinking there's thousands of
typefaces out there how can I possibly
choose five well don't worry because
I've done the hard work for you and
these five are ones that you can always
come back to these are easy to use
professional typefaces that will work
well in any project now the first
typeface that you can never go wrong
with is a really simple one it's been
around forever and it's hell vedica
helvetica is super clean it's modern it
can be used in a wide variety of
projects and it's one of my favorite
all-time go-to's helvetica has many
different font families within it and
there's also helvetica new which you
should 100 check out next example is
Universe this is a typeface I've been
using for years and years and years
super modern clean sans-serif amazing
typeface can be used across the board in
a variety of applications typeface
number three avenir sans-serif modern
always works absolutely love this one
typeface 4 garamond this is a great
serif typeface to use it's elegant it's
classic highly recommended typeface 5
fodani serif font classic can be used in
a variety of applications you can't go
wrong with this one now let me show you
an example here of how you can change
the look of a frame just by changing the
typeface now currently we're set to
helvetica bold on our main title the
website is how about a regular the
description copy is helvetica Lite as
well as the scene this is a pretty
common trick to use with typography
where you step down in size from a bold
to a regular to a light to create visual
interest on the screen and to kind of
break up the screen and create contrast
we could also change this helvetica
regular to an app near book and we could
change the two lights to an avenir light
it looks great it's super modern it's
clean it's easy to read now let's try a
serif font so for this we'll try bodani
we'll do a bulldani bold and we'll go
with a badani book for the smaller type
as well again it completely changes up
the look it's classic it's still easy to
read so in this approach we're using a
serif paired with a Sans serif which
works extremely well if you use the
right typefaces what's great about these
five typefaces is that they can be
interchanged they work really well
together or really well on their own so
those my friends are the five typefaces
I would absolutely be using in my motion
design work on an everyday basis I hope
that you really enjoy this lesson as
much as I loved teaching it so please
let me know if you have any questions in
the comments below I'd love to answer
them for you hit that like button if you
enjoyed this video and please subscribe
to this channel it helps other people
find this channel as well if you're
looking to upgrade your design skill set
master the art of style and execute like
a pro I have a course called stylecraft
that you can check out at
motionscience.tv you can also learn more
about this course by clicking the link
in the description below as always
thanks for watching my name is Cameron
and this is motion science
[Music]